combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
pâques ap le ch ne vous trompez pas on
était bien sur vos droits à moi d'en
voir un clou par ailleurs il en manque
ou quand tout con bonjour ma belle nous
allons être à ta ville tous les deux
pour acheter des clous j'espère que tu
es quand un patron dirai simplement ça
se fait mais fatigué tu n'est pourtant
pas sortie hier
allez allez allez un peu de courage pat
à roule alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça
un art ou pourquoi pas de parole ce
n'est pas très gentil
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu dis hanau
mais non il n'y a pas d'arbres qui
arrivait à les remettre à temps sur
cette fois c'est sérieux réveille toi et
en avant un nom sympa ta rôle tu deviens
folle ou quoi je te répète qu'il n'y a
pas d'arbres devant toi voyons tu étais
phare semble en bon état tu me vois flou
j'ai eu l'idée fatah êtes attaché
apporte-moi la pelle et le râteau
non j'ai je n'ai besoin que des manches
pourquoi fois tu verras bien plus tôt
c'est pas ta rôle qui verra bien
[Musique]
bon cette fois nous allons faire un
examen sérieux alors regarde bien à la
première ligne je vois tu pas tharoul
[Musique]
mais non pas n c'est un rat mais non pas
elle sait eu l'aubaine utile de
continuer je sais ce qu'ils te forme à
port pata roule
[Musique]
attention alors placé bien les branches
de chaque côté du capot voilà les verts
ne pensez pas voilà très bien hâte d'en
fixer le tout solidement bien voilà
parfait je vois bien ma petite patte
arul voilà tes lunettes plus de
problèmes d'arbre maintenant alors on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pas
taper je ne vous trompez pas compter
bien sûr vaudois il en manque un
[Musique]